Welcome to "The Next Level," everybody.
[applause]
- What's up?
- Hi, Tacarra.
- What's going on, Kev?
- How are you?
You look nice.
Oh, well, come on now.
Now, born in Belize--
- Yes.
- But from Bronx.
From the Bronx, right?
Raised right in the South
Bronx, right in the projects.
Raised.
TACARRA WILLIAMS: Raised.
TACARRA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
- Mommy and daddy, or--
- Mommy and daddy.
Mommy and daddy.
- Third-oldest of eight kids.
- What?
Yeah.
Same mommy and daddy?
No TV, no jobs,
no nothing, just--
KEVIN HART: Just--
- Just kids.
--smacking.
One out after the other.
Belly bumping.
TACARRA WILLIAMS:
Yeah, apparently.
I don't-- but I don't want that
visual, so if we could just--
And where are you at?
Where are you at
within the eight?
I am the third-oldest,
and a twin.
- And you got a twin?
- I do.
Twin brother or sister?
- Sister.
- What's your job?
What do you do?
OK.
So I am a life skills coach.
I'm a teacher.
And I work in all of the
jails in Southern California.
And what that is--
Sheesh.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm a little hard core.
I took some of that--
KEVIN HART: In the jail?
I took some of
that project with me.
So it works perfect.
The balance works perfect.
Now I mean, was it a--
was it an easy fit
right out of the gate,
or did it take some
getting used to?
Oh, it took some getting--
because you know, I'm cute.
So uh--
[laughter]
When you work in a jail
full of men, it is--
you just got to know how to
set your boundaries up front.
If not, they will
run some game on you.
But you know, growing
up in the projects--
[inaudible] I'm
gonna crack your head.
Saying stuff like that?
No.
I say, if you're going to
make me feel uncomfortable,
we going to all
be uncomfortable.
Is that what y'all want?
And then somebody be
like, nah, nah, chill.
No, chill, chill.
Chill, twin.
TACARRA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
Don't even act like that, twin.
Have you ever seen an inmate--
- Yes.
- Have you ever seen--
you didn't even
know the question!
[laughter]
Because it's questions
I get all the time.
And sometimes they
come to my shows.
Oh, are you serious?
To the point where I
can't even-- in the jail,
I'm just Miss C. I can't go by--
and that's a random initial,
just because they'll Google me
if I give them first or last.
They'll find me.
And then they pop
up at my shows.
And then after my show,
they be like, yo, Miss T!
No.
You don't remember me.
TACARRA WILLIAMS: That's
exactly what I say.
D block.
5000 floor.
You don't remember me?
KEVIN HART: 5000.
Remember when you locked
down the one dude?
It be like, woo woo!
Well, I would definitely
say this-- you
have lived an interesting life.
And I think interesting lives
make for amazing stories.
I think right now
it's time for you
to go to the next
level, Tacarra.
I am so ready.
You go to the next level.
You get them, people, day one.
You send me?
Go, Tacarra!